in the world of Agriculture two distinct
approaches dominate Hydroponics and
traditional farming these methods
represent the old and the new each with
its own philosophy and techniques each
offers a unique set of advantages and
disadvantages sparking debate about
which method Reigns Supreme Hydroponics
with its soilless systems promises
higher yields and efficient water use
while traditional farming relies on -
tested practices and natural soil
ecosystems
this essay delves into the intricacies
of both comparing their efficiency
environmental impacts costs and yields
we will explore how Hydroponics can
thrive in urban settings and how
traditional farming supports
biodiversity and Rural economies by
understanding the nuances of each we can
better determine which approach best
suits our needs and the future of food
production the data and insights from
agronomists and farmers will guide us in
this exploration this exploration is not
about crowning a Victor instead it seeks
to provide a balanced view recognizing
that both methods have their place in
the agricultural landscape instead it
aims to illuminate the strengths and
weaknesses of each approach empowering
individuals to make informed decisions
about the food they consume and how it
is produced by examining case studies
and real world applications we can see
the Practical implications of each
method the future of Agriculture may
very well lie in a harmonious blend of
tradition and Innovation embrace braing
both methods could lead to a more
sustainable and resilient food system
capable of meeting the demands of a
growing
population Hydroponics a method of
growing plants without soil captivates
the imagination with its futuristic
appeal instead of relying on the earth
plants are nourished by nutrient-rich
Water Solutions this technique opens
doors to cultivating food in
unconventional spaces from Urban
rooftops to control old indoor
environments imagine a world where fresh
produce is readily available regardless
of climate or geographical limitations
this is the promise of Hydroponics this
method offers a solution to land
scarcity reduces Reliance on pesticides
and minimizes water
usage traditional farming deeply
entwined with human history represents a
time-tested approach to food production
for centuries humans have tilled the
soil planted seeds and nurtured crops to
fruition this method reliant on natural
elements connects us to the land and The
rhythms of the seasons while some may
view traditional farming as archaic it
Remains the backbone of Global Food
production vast fields of wheat corn and
soybeans Staples in our diets are
cultivated through traditional methods
the sheer scale of traditional farming
underscore scores its importance in
feeding the
world when it comes to efficiency
Hydroponics takes the lead in terms of
space utilization by growing plants in
nutrient-rich water rather than soil
hydroponic systems can be set up in
urban environments rooftops and even
indoors making them incredibly versatile
vertical farming techniques allow
Growers to maximize yields within
limited areas these systems stack plants
in layers utilizing vertical space that
would otherwise go unused and can
produce significantly more food per
square foot compared to traditional
farming picture towering structures
bathed in the glow of grow lights
producing an abundance of food these
grow lights are specifically designed to
provide the optimal spectrum of light
for plant growth ensuring that each
plant receives the energy it needs to
thrive traditional farming on the other
hand requires vast expanses of land this
method of Agriculture has been the
backbone of food production for
centuries but it comes with its own set
of challenges Fields stretch as far as
the eye can see a testament to the scale
of production needed to feed the world's
population however this extensive land
use can lead to deforestation and loss
of natural habitats this land
requirement presents challenges in areas
where arable land is scarce in regions
with limited fertile soil traditional
farming can be less viable leading to
food shortages and increased pressure on
the environment water usage presents
another stark contrast hydroponic
systems are designed to use water more
efficiently than traditional farming
methods hydroponic systems excel in
water conservation often recirculating
nutrient solutions to minimize waste
this closed loop system ensures that
water is reused multiple times
significantly reducing the overall water
footprint traditional farming
particularly in Aid regions often relies
heavily on irrigation which can deplete
Water Resources this dependency on water
can be unsustainable especially in areas
prone to
Drought both Hydroponics and traditional
farming impact the environment albeit in
different ways Hydroponics while lauded
for its reduced water and pesticide use
can have a significant carbon footprint
depending on its energy source
traditional farming faces criticism for
its Reliance on pesticides and
fertilizers which can contaminate water
sources and harm beneficial insects
runoff from Fields Laden with chemicals
poses a threat to ecosystems however
sustainable farming practices such as
crop rotation and cover cropping are
gaining traction offering hope for a
more eco-friendly
[Music]
approach section six the price of
progress costs and Investments the
financial aspects of Hydroponics and
traditional farming present a complex
equation Hydroponics often demands a
higher initial investment ment the
technology equipment and infrastructure
required to establish a hydroponic Farm
can be substantial traditional farming
while requiring a lower initial
investment carries ongoing costs land
acquisition equipment maintenance and
the purchase of seeds fertilizers and
pesticides contribute to the financial
burden fluctuations in commodity prices
add an element of
uncertainty section s yields and growth
a Race Against Time in the realm of
yields and growth rates Hydroponics
demonstrates its prowess by precisely
controlling environmental factors such
as temperature humidity and nutrient
levels hydroponic Growers can optimize
plant growth traditional farming subject
to the whims of nature faces greater
variability in yields droughts floods
pests and diseases can decimate crops
leading to economic hardship for farmers
and food shortages Hydroponics offers a
greater degree of predictability
allowing for yearr round production
Cycles this reliability is particularly
appealing in regions with harsh climates
or limited growing
Seasons Section 8 sustainability
securing the future of food the
sustainability of Our Food Systems is
Paramount ensuring that we can feed the
growing global population without
depleting our natural resources is a
challenge we must address urgent ently
as the global population continues to
grow so too does the demand for food
urbanization and changing dietary
preferences further complicate the issue
making it essential to innovate and
adapt both Hydroponics and traditional
farming offer potential Solutions each
with its own set of challenges
Hydroponics can be implemented in urban
areas reducing the need for
transportation and ensuring fresh
produce Hydroponics with its reduced
water and land requirements presents a
compelling case for sustainable food
production it allows for year- round
cultivation and can be scaled vertically
maximizing space
efficiency however its Reliance on
energy often derived from fossil fuels
raises concerns the environmental
benefits of Hydroponics can be
undermined if the energy used is not
from renewable sources the Quest for
renewable energy sources is crucial to
mitigating the environmental impact of
Hydroponics solar panels and wind
turbines can provide the necessary power
without the Associated carbon footprint
traditional farming faces the daunting
task of feeding the world while
minimizing its ecological footprint
practices like minimal tillage and crop
rotation are essential for maintaining
soil health and biodiversity embracing
sustainable practices such as reducing
tillage planting cover crops and using
organic fertilizers can significantly
reduce the environmental impact of
traditional farming integrating
livestock into crop systems is essential
for preserving soil health and M
mitigating climate change this symbiotic
relationship enhances nutrient cycling
and reduces the need for chemical
inputs section N9 choosing your
agricultural Adventure so which method
Reigns Supreme the answer as with many
things in life is nuanced Hydroponics
with its efficiency and ability to grow
food and unconventional spaces holds
promise for urban Agriculture and
regions with limited resources
traditional farming despite its
challenges remains essential for feeding
the world's population embracing
sustainable practices and investing in
agricultural research are crucial for
ensuring its long-term
viability ultimately the choice between
Hydroponics and traditional farming
depends on a multitude of factors
including geographic location available
resources and personal values perhaps
the most sustainable path forward lies
in a hybrid approach embracing the
strengths of both methods to create a
resilient and Equitable food system